Hello everybody and welcome to episode
8, the final episode of buying and
selling in freetoplay Runescape. I am
very excited. I've enjoyed freeto play,
but I'm really looking forward to having
access to more items. Uh we're starting
the episode at about 4.2 mil, so we only
need 800k and then we can finally buy
the bond. Let's just have a look at our
history here. Doing really well. We got
the arrows done. So, we're just going to
find couple new items and then we'll
finally have 5 mil and we can get the
bond, which will be super exciting.
Okay, so let's just jump right into it
here. And for our first item here, we
are going to do the gilded plate skirt.
Uh we tried this before, but we didn't
manage to actually buy it. Um so we're
going to try again. We can check here.
It's between 290 approximately and 320
is the margin about. You can kind of see
the graph there. Um so I think we're
going to buy them around the 290 mark.
And hopefully we can get a couple this
time. Uh so yeah, we'll do 287 and we'll
buy five. You know what? Screw it. We're
going to go for 10.
We have spent forever looking for a
second item here. So, I think we're
going to go with the raw tuna. It has a
3GP margin on it uh right now. And it
looks pretty promising. Uh we can
probably buy a bit. So, yeah, you can
see there. And you can see a whack of
other items I tried. Um so, yeah, we'll
go with the raw tuna. I think we're
going to buy 15,000 of them. Um so, if
we buy the 15,000, get a 3GP margin on
it. Still like 45k. Um so, our money
isn't just idling because I cannot find
anything else.
Okay, so with the uh rest of our money
here, I think we're just going to dump
it into the Myithil plate legs. Uh we
are checking it here. It actually has a
6K margin on it, which is really good. I
can see we bought it for nine and uh we
sell it here, I think, for 3K. That's
exactly a 6K margin, which is good. Uh
if it stays that way, and we only have
like 300k left to buy stuff with. So,
this is a nice cheap item with a really
big of margin on it still. Um so, we'll
try to buy like 50 or 60 of these. And
we'll pop back when uh everything has
bought and sold. Okay, so we've sold
everything here. Uh the 2 and0 we got
one GP on, so really nothing. Just like
15k here. Uh the plate skirts we've sold
in kind of two different offer slots
because the um the other item we were
buying didn't buy at all. Um so we sold
two of the plate skirts for a um 28k
margin because we sold them for 315k.
You can see there. So we made 56k on two
of them and the other rest uh that we've
sold was six. We sold at 22k margin um
for 126k profit. So in total we made
about uh 180k off that so far which is
really good. Plus we have two more to
sell after consulting OS buddy. Uh we
are just going to dump them for what we
bought them for. So 289k. So uh we've
made about 180k on the flip and we'll
just leave it at
that. So we noticed the uh myithal
arrows seem to have actually a 4 GP
margin on it which is really good for
the price point. Um, so we bought them
for 46 and sold them for 42. Um, so
we'll buy them 20k of them and we'll get
them for 42 hopefully. 60k. Oh my god,
that's ambitious. I don't remember doing
that. For the final item here, um, you
can see the party hats have a 10k margin
in them right now, which is really good.
Um, so we're going to go buy some of
these. Again, they're really quick to
flip, so the fact that they have a 10k
margin, we can make an easy couple
hundredk here. U, we're going to buy
them for around the 56k mark. I think
we're going to buy 20. So, if we
actually get 10k on each, we'll get 200k
out of this, which is really awesome.
Um, so yeah, we'll check back when it's
done. Okay, so everything is sold here.
The uh plate skirt we just broke even
on, so we'll just ignore that. That's
nothing. Uh, the myithil arrows, we
actually still managed to get the 4GP
margin on that. So, we got about uh 110k
off that transaction. Uh, we'll get the
history open
here. Yep. So, you can see there about
110k.
Yeah. And the party hats, we still got a
5,500 GP margin on them, even though it
dropped a little bit. Um, but we get 16
of those. Um, so we got about 90k from
the party hats, which puts us at 4.5
mil. So, we're so close. Just a couple
more flips. Uh, so let's just get at it
and get this done. So, for the first
item, we're going to think we're going
to do the party hats again. Uh, cuz they
still have a decent margin in there.
Really quick to flip, which is nice. Um,
so we bought them for exactly 60K and
sold them for 52. So that's still an 8K
margin on there. That's still really
good. Um, so we'll go ahead. We're going
to buy a bunch of these this time
because they're really quick and they're
really profitable. Um, so we'll go buy
them for about 5250 or something like
that. And uh, I think we're going to buy
like 50 of these or 60. 50. So that's a
large chunk of our cash stacks going
into this, but it's really good item.
And for the second item here, we're
going to try the gilded plate skirt
again. Uh they did work pretty well and
uh I think we'll be able to buy them for
cheaper again this time. Uh so we're
going to go buy them for about 280k each
and hopefully we'll get a 20 30k margin
on them again. This time I think we're
going to buy
five. Okay. So I can't really find a
good item. Uh but we don't really have a
lot of money left anyway. So we're just
going to go buy some of this tuna cuz it
still has a 3GP marge on it. And we'll
just use the rest of our money up here.
And uh yeah, we'll come back when we've
uh bought and sold these. Okay, so we
have sold everything here. The uh raw
tuna, we only got one GP on each. So
that's just 8k from the tuna. Uh the
gilded plate skirts, we got about 20k on
each one, so that is 100k actually from
those, which is pretty nice. And the
party hats, we got about exactly 7K on
each. Uh which is 35k, which is not too
bad. We didn't actually manage to buy
too many of those. I can kind It's kind
of hard to tell because I've broken up
the purchases. I think we only actually
got four. We just bought another one to
check the margin. Uh so we actually only
got four. So, we only got 28k out of
that. So, whatever. So, we have 380k
left till 5 mil. I don't know if we can
do this in one flip, but I think what
we're going to try to do is set it up so
if everything goes to plan, we can get
it done with this last flip here. So,
let's give it a try. The price of the
plate skirts have dropped a bit, so
we're going to buy them for 269K each,
and we're going to try to buy 14 of
them. This will give us the bulk of the
profit, assuming we buy them all and
sell them for a decent price. So
hopefully that goes well. So once again
here I think we're going to do the raw
tuna. It had a 3GP margin on it and I'm
struggling to find another item that
would work. But I mean whatever. We'll
put some money into the raw tuna here.
It's pretty consistent. So hopefully
we'll get a little bit of it. But for 57
each and we'll use the bulk of our
money, but we'll save a bit just for one
final item. Uh which we're going to
determine in a second here.
And for our very last item, hopefully uh
when buying and selling free play
Runescape, we are going to do the
Myithil play legs. Uh we checked them.
They had a decent margin on them. So
we'll buy a couple of these with the
remainder of our money. Don't have
enough for 30. Let's reduce that a bit.
And uh yeah, so we'll leave these in for
a while. We'll try to buy them all. And
we'll check back hopefully when
everything's sold and we should be
done. All right, it's all sold. So I
think we have enough here. Um, well, I
know I do cuz I record these clips
after. Uh, but yeah. So, we'll just run
down the last flip. I did manage to get
5 mil of this. So, we're going to claim
everything here. It's so perfect
actually. And play legs. And look at
that. Bam. 5 mil and 29K. Um, so we
ended up making on the plate skirts the
most money. We got 20k on each one, you
can see, which gave us about 280k
profit, which is massive, especially for
free to play. plate legs, we got 8 and a
halfk on each one, and we got 11 of
those, giving us about 95k in profit.
And the tuna, we got a 2GP margin for
24k to round things up. We actually
would have been fine without the tuna
flip, but you know what? Screw it. So,
there we go. We're up to 5 mil. We'll
shortly here buy a bond. First though, I
just want to have a quick look at my
character here. So, we have 5 mil and
29k. Let's just have a quick look at my
bank here. Literally nothing. Those are
just the starter items. So, I did not do
anything except for standing G buying
and selling. So, it's really not too
hard. You don't need any requirements.
You can look at my skills here. I mean,
I got I don't even know how I got four
cooking, but I have four cooking. I
think I got it from the quest I needed
just to unlock the GE. So, the plan now
is we're going to buy the bond. And I
was going to wait and do some prep work
on my main account, but now I think I'm
just going to buy it right now. And uh
so, going forward, what we're going to
do is we're going to try to flip enough
money to renew the bond every week. And
what I'm going to do is at the corner of
every clip I now go forward with,
there's going to be a counter for what
day I am on my membership. Um, so you
can see how successful I am. I will need
about 200k every day approximately to be
able to sustain the bond. Um, so I'm not
sure how realistic this is going to be.
If it really becomes impossible, I will
just buy it and uh we'll just flip GP.
But um, we're going to come up with a
new goal. Uh, but the goal in mind is
going to be renewing the bond with the
earnings. So, I'd like to hear from you
guys. Uh, what do you think would be a
realistic goal? Uh, 20 mil, a 50 mil,
100 mil, a bill. Um, because you have to
keep in mind every week I'm going to
have to be buying membership. Uh, sorry,
every two weeks. Uh, which I need to
sustain. So, it's going to be kind of
challenging at first. Um, what do you
think is a good strategy? Do you think I
should buy one bond at a time or do you
think I should save up for five bonds?
Because they have a summer special going
on which gives you three months of
membership uh for five bonds. Uh, it's
going to be kind of interesting to see
what the most economical strategy going
forward will be. But yeah, if you guys
have any ideas, just leave a comment
below. And yeah, I will see you guys
next time.
[Music]